in the authentic uh swing you talk about
it's sort of a behind-the-scenes look at
how how the the book came about and
ultimately the movie came about um what
is it about can you speak to
how golf works for you as this analogy
for
these other these other ideas because
it's it it does
like it's it's counter-intuitive and yet
it completely makes sense when you
explain it
um first of all i know that people who
are not into golf it seems like a dopey
is sporting yeah i'm not into i'm i'm
like
i have i'm not into golf at all like i
have a hard time although i watched the
tiger documentary and i was riveted by
that
well they say about golf and it's really
really true that with
almost any other sport if you don't play
it and you see it like say motor racing
or
or surfing or uh mountain climbing even
if you don't play it you can look at it
and go oh that looks kind of cool
you know look at laird hamilton going
down that you know but golf is an
exception you look at golf you go it's a
bunch of white guys
you know wearing plaid pants it seems
like the fat guys it's donald trump it's
like
the most poor but trust me it's a great
sport
and to prove it michael jordan loves it
john elway loves it you know tom brady
so
anyway um the one thing about golf you
were talking about the authentic swing
before is
like i had two friends when i was uh a
kid
identical twins who played golf and the
amazing thing to me was they had
abs completely different golf swings and
i thought shouldn't they have the exact
same swing they're the same
dna and it is true that
in some crazy way we're born with a
swing before we ever pick up a club
you have a swing i have a swing
everybody around here has a swing
and you cannot change that swing if you
think about
golfers like fred couples or jim furyk
that have these crazy
loopy swings they didn't they didn't
evolve that through study
so to me the idea of the authentic swing
and finding your authentic swing
is the equivalent of of your authentic
self it's what we were talking about
before about
being born in as with a gift and and
that's
and that's it and so a lot of us
like in golf people will try to mold
themselves into some perfect
kind of a swing and it never works and
the real answer is
if you can to find your own authentic
swing
and then you know fine tune it so that
you don't have bad habits in there
and so i think that's the same thing in
in writing in art or anything in our
life is finding who who we are we we
already
are that thing and and uh
if we can just find it and be it but
that's the hardest thing in the world
that's why they say know thyself
is like the hardest thing in the world
to do right but that's what we're here
to do
right and and to extend the golf
metaphor there is this
um truth in that
it's not about anyone other than
yourself
and your relationship with yourself like
you're yes
it is the ultimate individual sport
right and this idea
that you talk about of of um
i forget how you phrase it exactly but
most
most athletes are reacting
without a forethought in the moment
whether they're you know
hitting a backhand or you know uh
blocking a jump shot but in golf there's
stillness
which forces you to you know engage with
your thinking mind which moves you away
from the ability to execute on what
you're there to do
and it's all about the process of
getting out of your own way
right and that goes back to the
stripping away thing in bagger with
you know the the um the you know who
are you question to eradicate all the
noise so that you can be
fully present yes and
like as you're saying golf is one of the
few sports
maybe shooting a free throw or kicking a
field goal is a parallel
where you do it from a standing start
like you say in basketball you know
you're reacting to somebody or tennis
the ball's coming you react to it
and it's easier to do that in motion
it's more it's easier to do it
but from a standing start where your
brain starts working
but then there's a whole other aspect of
golf
that was in uh this book the authentic
swing
and this is kind of a crazy thing and it
gets spiritual is that
there's really no other sport where you
have a caddy
where you have another person standing
at your shoulder
that technically is your servant right
you're paying them to carry the bag
but as we all know the bond
between the caddy and the golfers and
and in
um in the bhagavad-gita where you have
the great warrior arjuna
his charioteer is krishna i.e god in
human form
and that was the parallel that i drew
like so god appears as a servant
at your side and a kind of an advisor
and i think that
a lot of uh of christians who believe in
a personal savior related to the the
character of bag or vance that way
but i also do think if you think about i
know we're getting in a deep water
this is my this is the stuff i love the
most if you think about
um the odyssey and odysseus
as he's on his journey we people forget
about this
he's accompanied by the goddess athena
and he talks to her all the time and she
intercedes for him
and um uh anybody that uh
you know martin luther king or somebody
would talk to jesus all the time
like he was at his shoulder and so the
same thing
with uh arjuna the great warrior and
krishna is at his side
as an instructor and as a divine
archetype
and i do think this is when i say i
believe in the muse
and although resistance is the negative
side of it
the goddess is the positive side of it
that you know when i said i was
seized by the story of bagger vance had
to write it that's what that was it was
coming
from another so that was the equivalent
of
of uh krishna at your shoulder or athena
or jesus
or whatever some
entity from another dimension of reality
from a dimension of
potentiality where do songs come from
where do ideas come from where
books come from um i think there's a lot
of reality so back to golf
the idea in golf that you have this
person
at your shoulder that guides you and you
can see if you watch a golf tournament
you watch phil mickelson or tiger or
whatever
you know they're taught they turn to
caddy all the time the caddy saves them
you know
in other sports you don't have michael
jordan can't stop and confer
with you know or anything like that
right um
so i i do think that there's there's a
real
spiritual aspect to that or at least a
metaphor for something
right right yeah and that's one of the
reasons why
the tiger documentary was so interesting
hearing the perspective of his caddy
have you seen that documentary yeah
yeah and then when when tiger fires him
and the guy's like i
you know i mean it's such a sacred
relationship
yeah that seemed to be a real turning
point in terms of how
tiger was approaching the world at that
point in his life i think so
yeah and like you know dustin johnson
i don't know if he's like one number one
or whatever he is now his brother is his
caddy
and they've been like and he's a real
good player too his brother austin
and somehow that's in a way a secret to
his success that you can see these two
brothers
are you know really in it together it's
not a one-man fight it's a two-minute
fight
right
[Music]
you